ces jeunes femmes noircel je ne fais que
donner son point de vue c'est pas du
tout voilà ces jeunes femmes Marcel lors
de sa garde à vue il a pleuré il a
réussi à être assez convaincant pour le
moment c'est pour ça qu'il n'y a pas eu
de charges retenu contre lui c'est le
mélange pour l'instant aucune chance de
changer il faut vraiment le dire quand
même avec la jeune québécoise
épreuve victime sont en attente d'être
entendu minimise pas du tout je dis
simplement que pour le moment l'enquête
de continuer qu'il n'y a pas de charge
ce mec il a il a il maintenant il a sa
femme son ses enfants il adapté sa fille
il a tout il a bien sûr qu'il va essayer
de minimiser l'effet parce que là il est
il vit sa best live quoi il va pas envie
de tout perdre donc c'est normal après
franchement je trouve que c'est un petit
peu un petit peu abusé de dire que on
aurait que ça à faire en 2015 d'inventer
autant de conversations etc on était
tellement petite c'était le début des
réseaux sociaux voilà quoi moi j'avais
une journaliste qui c'était arrivé avec
avec